you have to be careful and you have to
stand up and we've got a situation where
the police are there was a guy in
homicide who retweeted a poem which was
deemed to be transphobic and then the
police phoned him up and said we need to
check your thinking on this
and he said well what's my crime and
they said and I'm not kidding they said
this is a non crime hate incident
I want the state to stay out of people's
private lives oh you know I find that I
you know we've in the UK they've already
proven that they don't they can't be
trusted on all sorts of issues you know
the fact that they're criminalizing
people who tell certain jokes for
instance the fact that they don't see
the difference between a joking and the
literal truth that means that to me I
don't want them getting involved in
curving people's speech you know and I
think that the free spirit I mean you've
got a First Amendment you're okay yeah
so no no we don't have that and we we
have an unwritten Constitution which
means it's constantly being
reinterpreted and sometimes quite badly
so as a free speech guy and a guy that's
out there doing pretty controversial
stuff how cognitive are you aware that
you don't have the First Amendment right
so comedians here you can say whatever
you want yeah you know every time Trump
tweets these edgy comedians tweet you
know they tell them to you know go kiss
offer yeah yeah whatever yeah because
every running Trump doesn't send the
police
the Gestapo doesn't knock on the door
you're good to go yeah but in the UK you
don't have certain protection we okay so
it doesn't affect me so much so I've
never made the claim that I'm being
silenced right I'm actually a really
privileged position I don't have a boss
I can say whatever I want I'm a comedian
and a writer so I do say whatever I want
I've never felt that I'm being censored
the the concern is that actually the
people who do I mean look say if I was
still a teacher could I send the tweets
that I send at the moment absolutely not
I would get in a lot of trouble
I know people who who have got in
trouble at work because I think jokes
they've made or things that have been
misconstrued a lot of people over in the
UK are now talking to their friends at
work over whatsapp which means that
their jokes get encrypted right so
that's really weird isn't the idea you
must encrypt your jokes I mean you know
hates theirs okay by a company that's
owned by Facebook right right there we
go yeah that's great yeah so I mean on
the whole I think we do have freedoms
but I don't think there's a big freedom
of speech crises what I mean is it
have to be vigilant about it you have to
be careful you have to stand up and
we've got a situation where the police
are there was a guy in homicide who
retweeted a poem which was deemed to be
transphobic and then the police phoned
him up and said we need to check your
thinking on this
and he said well what's my crime and
they said and I'm not kidding they said
this is a non crime hate incident and
that's standard police practice so
that's not so that's a worry well so
every few weeks I see one of those
tweets it's usually from the Sussex
Police right is that is that who it's
all over the place I mean it's it's it's
it's it's West Yorkshire Police it's
been the Glasgow police as well it's
very Police Department they literally
tweet out things like if someone that
you know said something that you might
have taken offense to yes let us know
right exactly and I think much more
Orwellian can you get right and and you
know whenever you use that word
Orwellian people say you're being cliche
there is no other word for it what else
are you going to call it this is this is
that's exactly what it is so so while
I'm sorry you know this isn't to the
point of a kind of authoritarian state
right but when you see these things you
have to stand up and say no this is it
you know we can't have this we've got to
get rid of this and and if you don't
that's where the slippery slope begins
what do you think it's partially that
people just don't stand up so for
example you can't doing what you're
doing we know Douglas Murray and Peter
Lloyd and Paul Joseph Watson I mean
there's a plenty of people all over the
political spectrum yeah do stand up to
it they haven't grabbed people and
brought them to the gulags yet but it's
just like we just need more people to
stand up and then they'll well kind of
paper tiger disappeared I think the
trick is you've got to stand up for
people you don't like and that's the I
mean what I mean it what I understand
why people don't want to don't want to
stand up for the the right thing I don't
know there's a thing called preference
falsification where you you say what you
think is going to be best received as
opposed to what you actually think and I
understand that impulse because I mean
it's a protection is it's kind of shield
but if everyone's a bit more courageous
and you know when I defend someone's
right to say something and I don't like
what they've said
invariably I get I get told that I'm
endorsing what they've said so this is
fundamental to misunderstanding I think
generally with free speech is a kind of
fundamental misunderstanding of what of
what it is you know nobody is saying
there shouldn't be consequences to
speech nobody's saying that they're
saying that if you're consequent if you
want to argue back ridicule whatever you
know that's a protest even that's great
great all for it right it's
when you get the police involved you
know and it's not the same as perjury or
libel laws or those kind of things which
or harassment or they which are already
covered by law you know we we talk about
you know and the other one I get all the
time is though well you can't shout fire
in a theater actually you can but you're
a bit of a [ __ ] I'm gonna be honest
if you do that that the the theater
authorities are well within their rights
to ask you to leave right there's a
little there's a little confusion like
some legal confusion that has sort of
become lore about the fire in a crowded
theater it's not it's not true yeah you
incite a riot basically is the right
like there's some so with the incitement
of honest thing I'd like I imagine there
are circumstances where there's a mob
and someone's you know talking to the
mob and saying go and get that person
yeah you can't do right sure so we have
laws that cover incitement to violence
but the trouble is and this is another
example of the state getting it wrong so
recently we had to debate in the UK
Parliament because Boris Johnson the
Conservatives were using language like
the surrender bill to describe a bill
that relates to the BRICS and
negotiations and they were accused of
using military language which incites
violence it's called a metaphor right
honestly like so many people on the sort
of liberal left social justice group
they don't understand basic metaphor
they don't understand it they don't
understand jokes right they they take
them completely literally right there's
an example of this that there's a
comedian called Andrew Lawrence in the
UK who posted a joke online and I'll say
what the joke is probably is offensive
right so this was the joke so the
journal yeah brace yourself right yes
okay so the joke was basically that the
the statistics on suicide between men
and women are not comparable and so you
know more men kill themselves than women
so therefore if feminists really care
about equality they should kill them
sick right now are they okay right now
it's not the joke and it's not people
being offended I think people should be
allowed to be offended and they've got
the right to be offended that's not the
issue there was a petition which called
for him to be you know D platform from
the BBC even prosecuted and what they
said was this was inciting women to kill
themselves right now if your opinion of
women is that low yeah but you think
they're so stupid that there is just
these little drones that just will kill
themselves they hear a joke about it and
that concerns me this kind of literal
mindedness about metaphor about jokes
about art you know you get that in
Hollywood all the time like we need to
represent women in a certain way so
let's make the Charlie's Angels reboot
which nobody wants to see because it's
just it's clearly social engineering
it's
you people you're you're you you think
the wrong way and we wear that we're the
Hollywood people we can tell you how you
should be thinking yeah people it's so
that is rhubarb ative to people it just
puts people off its announcing this this
idea that we have to take all of these
old movies that were classics yeah and
just remake them with women as if as if
the women can't watch the old one
appreciate its I mean the Ghostbusters
is the easiest example is I mean when
they did the all women remake I watch it
I didn't I have no problem watching a
tall woman cast of ghostbusters but the
movie was freaking hard ya know what no
one cares about this stuff like this is
the thing about this thing you don't
need to educate these fans my particular
science fiction fans particular comic
book fans you know they've done this a
lot with sort of changing the genders
and the race and the sexual orientation
of various major characters and so these
are already the outsiders these
comic-book fans these are people who
have no issues with this you
it's like someone it's like a school
mistress sort of finger-pointing and
jabbing at people when they don't need
that education it generates a lot of
resentment people hate it do you think
it's also sort of funny I think
especially with the gay thing the way
that they sneak in these messages so
it's like like the two that I could
think of and I'm sure you have like a
gajillion more but that really struck me
as like they're just like smacking you
with this in the worst way yeah is in
Avengers endgame yeah they had the one
gay character was just the guy in rehab
yeah who I guess maybe went on a date
with a guy in Captain America is like
good for you like that I was throwing
the gays like the tiniest bone yeah yeah
it was just like I see we did something
gay yeah nothing to do with the
superheroes or anyone you give a [ __ ]
about but it's something gay yeah and
then the other one was in in rise of
Skywalker yeah we're at the end that
woman has that lesbian kiss and it's
like again it's not a real character
it's not anyone anyone cares about but
we did something for the case so it's
just like take our little pity what
that's that yeah but also like the case
don't need your pity right mean it like
I don't need to see pink stormtroopers
and I don't need to see gay people in
Star Wars for me to feel okay about
stuff you know it's okay anyway there's
been c-3po for years there has been
getting representation and all of the
Star Wars fan system alerted you to have
been in a robo sexual relations yeah
explicit yeah and I don't need to see
that I mean they did you know they did
the same with Avengers like you say they
did the same with the the JK Rowling the
the fantastic beast stuff and they were
saying that it wasn't gay enough this is
a point so you've got Dumbledore but
it's not explicitly again
what do you want to see you want to see
him I want to see him I know getting
fisted or something I mean they say is
that really what you need I kind of say
that sorry I don't know I mean I don't
need I don't know that people want to
hear you say you know I know sure what
you are getting fisted is bad I don't
write I think it's really patronizing
yeah I think ultimately that's what it
is like so so much of what drives what I
do is I hate the way these people
patronize minority groups I hate that
because I think they're it's the
opposite of what they say it is right so
if you claim to be fourth wave feminism
right which claims to be all about
empowerment of women it's not it's about
treating them like children it's about
victimizing them it's actually genuinely
misogynistic but it's but it's sort of
papered over with this kind of sheen of
we're doing something progressive that I
don't think there's anything progressive
about any of this stuff and the other
thing I hate about it is I think it
legitimizes bullying I think the social
justice movement that's I I hate bullies
I can't stand them right and if you if
you stand up against them they get even
more vicious right you must have noticed
this right so it's it's funny all of the
signals about how good you are like
putting pronouns in your bio on Twitter
or putting a rainbow flag up there on
Twitter why is it whenever I get
brutally attacks on Twitter those are
the people when I go to their bio Oh Pro
knows what and I'm not saying that the
pronouns themselves are or making a
connection with trans people I wanted a
legitimate answer to this so that's this
question before why is it the case that
the most vicious the most bullying and
the most unpleasant characteristics tend
to come from those people I don't know
why if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell